this is howard crozier dancing in his
nursing home
months later he caught covered and died
his daughter susie says she's stuck to
the rules to protect people like her
father she is furious with the prime
minister and the chancellor we have been
mocked by the leadership of this country
um the bereaved in particular mocked by
the leaders of this country and as far
as i'm concerned both of them need to
resign these messages were broadcast
just days before howard died i want to
thank everyone who's been following the
clear rules that we set out we all stand
together
susie is not the only one who thinks
fines for those who made the
restrictions must have severe
consequences
57 of people surveyed think the prime
minister and the chancellor should now
resign and 75 think that boris johnson
knowingly lied about breaking the rules
we asked commuters in manchester whether
he should go i think he should resign
personally he's made other people resign
i just feel like it'll be a bit of a
chip in his armor instead of actually
making a full difference i still believe
uh
it has not come to the extent that he
has to resign
callum harrison is angry because he too
received a fine for attending a social
gathering he thinks the pm's actions
undermine all of the notices that have
been served and would like to be
reimbursed along with anyone else who
received one i think if i dig a refund
i'd go to charity i'm not first about
the money it's more just sort of the
principles that the government should be
setting examples you should be following
them as well we broke the rules we both
broke in in a similar sort of way but
i'm not the one setting examples i'm not
the one setting the rules
i'm not the one leaving the country
setting example for everyone else
and that's the crux of this for so many
people they didn't take this virus
seriously to start with and their
behavior just proves that they didn't
take it seriously but it's not just the
bereaved who feel betrayed and if the
prime minister and chancellor stay in
their positions they'll have to convince
voters it was the right decision becky
cottrell sky news manchester